bonjour à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france 1500 listes de
candidatures approuvées donc pour ces
législatives anticipées qui sont fixé au
12 juin prochain est ce que c'est une
avancée pour le pays oui bien sûr il
faut le rappeler aussi en avril 2019 une
révolution a eu lieu un président déchu
il n'a pas réussi à voir son cinquième
mandat de premier ministre qui sont
admis l'excellent l'alarmé douillard ils
sont en prison
aussi plusieurs hommes d'affaires
corrompus donc énorme révolution a eu
lieu après c'est quoi après la
révolution on a toujours une semaine
qu'on appelle la fièvre révolutionnaire
c'est un phénomène qui a accompagné par
exemple la révolution française de 14
juillet 1789 on en passe qu'un siècle la
même chose en tunisie la même chose
aussi en algérie ça veut dire le citoyen
se sont un courage et se sont fort donc
de son talent dans la rue mais laraque
de ce deuxième irak
en fait et n'est pas comme le premier le
premier acte à réaliser ses objectifs
le deuxième on a fait des analyses
sociologiques qui sont ces mails étant
en majorité sont soit les séparatistes
de mac qui se lève toujours le trap aux
berbères qui n'est pas le drapeau
national de l'algérie qui n'est pas le
le drapeau de la révolution algérienne
de l'état algérien
et puis les islamistes du fis ce parce
que les islamistes en algérie sont
divisés il ya les frères musulmans à
metz qui sont intégrés au pouvoir et qui
sont pour les élections il y à aussi ce
qu'il reste des militants des fils nos
sorts copé dans un mouvement qui
s'appelle un chad et ils sont alliés
avec les séparatistes mcl les extrêmes
on a un petit souci technique avec vous
riadh sidaoui on va essayer de rétablir
la liaison je sais pas si vous continuez
à m'entendre
bon le irak justement il continue à
battre le pavé
tous les vendredis dans l'optique
certainement de ces législatives
anticipées
est-ce que l'irak même le irak constitue
quand même une force en présence à
prendre en compte en vue de ce scrutin
ou pas aujourd'hui la règle qui n'est
pas comme dit comme l'un des thèmes de
2019 avec 2019 ville avait comme slogan
chargé car je traduis armée et hop le
nous sommes des frères
la même chose armée police ce sont des
frères or c'est à deuxième craxi
minorité faut dire qu'ils se compose d
aider mais l'étendue mccaw des militants
de l'ex fils et qui attaque directement
l'institution militaire c'est pour cela
la revue de l'armée james a signalé ce
dérapage
donc aujourd'hui la date d'aujourd'hui
ce n'est pas lui même la raque de 2019
est-ce que la ra mauricienne de se
structurer et et d'être une force une
force de proposition à politique en vue
de ces législatives ou pas
comme j'ai dit il ya au moins toujours
lieu de r aquo lala qui a fait jeter
boutaflika et une deuxième le 10ème le
10e et ses composés des minorités
politiques je vous parle des mac et de
la chaîne deux mots la laïque et l'autre
islamistes intégristes mais sans trouver
dans un même front une alliance
objective face au régime mais avec les
élections puis avec la participation des
islamistes modérés des islamistes du
hamas les frères musulmans la version
des frères mimoun algérie
donc ces élections devant avoir lieu va
avoir lieu au mois de juin
évidemment peut-être le taux de
participation n'est pas très élevé mais
comme le dit lui même on peut pas parler
de miracle callum de 2019 et les plus le
maroc d'aujourd'hui est donc s'agissant
précisément des partis islamistes
quel est leur poids en vue de cette
élection des scellés
jusque là tee d'anticiper les islamistes
du hamas qui sont comme jeudi les frères
musulmans de l'algérie ont toujours été
et est toujours un accord avec le
pouvoir ils ont ils ont eu des
portefeuilles des ministre dans
plusieurs gouvernements et toujours les
appels à la participation
parce que ce parce qu'ils sont pas
violents comme le fisc a été dissous par
le pouvoir
rappelons la guerre civile ou ou la
décennie noire des années 90 donc les
islamistes de qui représente une partie
de la classe moyenne mais aussi
peut-être une partie de l'ère de la
classe défavorisée
parce que les islamistes des frères
musulmans comme le savons bien soin
tunisie en algérie au lit ou en egypte
ils utilisent toujours ce que nous
appelons l'islamisation par le bas ça
veut dire par la voix de la charité pépé
l'étape sont dès qu'il est alors en plus
pas ses devoirs en tant qu'etat de
providence walsh restait alors les
islamistes et socialement économiquement
les couches défavorisées ou et peuvent
récolter des voix pendant les élections
l'une des promesses d'abdelmajid
tebboune ans était de mettre cette
élection à l'abri de l'argent il ya une
loi électorale qui a abouti au rejet de
1200 listes de candidatures au motif
justement d'une proximité avec de
l'argent dix salles est ce que cette loi
finalement elle est efficace pour lutter
contre ce que l'on appelle les achats de
conscience pour réglementer le
financement de la campagne électorale
qui va débuter le 17 mai al majid boon
est conscient que la vie politique
pendant les 20 ans des reines et de
bonne partie des cas a été largement
corrompu c'est pour cette raison peut
être les plus grands milliardaires de
l'algérie sont actuellement présentes
pour des peines qui dépassent parfois
disons jeu puisque s'en donne en public
comme aller à dette
comme m'a dit tu as tout incite ainsi de
suite donc la correction et l'alliance
entre les politiques corrompus et lé
milliardaire algérien a été a été la
dessine la liste surtout la deuxième du
cygne est de 2 l'an 2000 donc âge et à
beaune est conscient il faut couper
entre l'argent et l'argent sale et les
élections et la vie politique donc on
veut des des élites politiques entre des
élites politiques propres qui ne sont
pas impliqués dans la corruption
merci beaucoup à vous riadh sidaoui et
vous êtes politologue directeur du
centre arabe de recherche et d'analysé
politique et sociale oke arabes se situe
à genève en suisse